the trick is trying to think like a cat
it's one thing to think boo to be like
if I were a cat it's another thing to
try to figure out well what is it like
for a cat to be a cat so I've different
ways of creating purr kind of says David
Thai classical musician mostly by trade
play the cello in the National Symphony
and that came up with the idea of
writing music for cats
you're my bird songs for study
let's slow them down cats are not very
vocal and not particularly social the
ultimate goal is to be able to
communicate in something like their
language
what other sounds are there that you
know cats would enjoy most of the brain
development of cat happens outside the
womb
I thought the sound of suckling is a
reward related sound that all cats will
have heard as their brains were forming
this swishing kind of sound yeah I would
totally use that could I name that after
your jacket that's my Louie W swish
another example of a sound is occurring
when you play this music how does a cat
react exactly there are things like they
would rub up against the speakers it
shows kind of ownership and but showing
just attention and it tends to be more
comforting to those cats who have had
something of a hard life because the
cats who need more comfort are more
comforted by it do you have a cat no no
I actually don't I'm allergic to cats
you're allergic to cats
you